lennier first of all uh tell us about
that long 35 minute thing did your
opponent surprise you did you know
anything about the position what were
you thinking during that long thing yeah
it's typical for me i always
take this long thing at some point and
uh
but okay the position was very solid for
black but many options probably all
leading to more or less the same type of
position
i i was
i was not sure about the move dc5
because it looks like the knight comes
with tempo to c5 and
uh it looks a bit
uh
a bit weird for black but not really i
think the position is good and i was
afraid of some cd6 and bishop a6 stuff i
was thinking something like queen 7
instead of dc was also possible did you
consider d5
yeah i thought the d5 as well but then
yeah it's probably also playable i mean
it's a different type of position but i
wanted to
yeah be more solid yeah this and takes
king h8 works for black right yes
yeah i mean it's probably around equal
anyway uh
sorry
irena has 100 match with a drone
and she will advance with this draw
handshake
perfect
go ahead uh linear yeah no as i was
saying it's just a very solid position
in general and i think what i played is
good enough
just to
to keep the
normal position and uh yeah at some
point
i
uh after this
knight b3 a5 it was upon sack because he
could take on c6 but i i felt that the
black hat has too many
uh has too much activity here like queen
takes the six a4
and maybe knight d2 but it looks
i mean risky for white because all the
pieces now on the d file uh i can play
rook fd8
so yeah queen c5 was was logical but
yes queen d8
yeah okay here uh i think if black just
stays with dba then something like rook
a7 or v6 it's very very close to just uh
just a draw
so
lanier if you don't uh mind me asking
because it's like one of those uh
confusing moments in chess where here
you are you're thinking for 30 minutes
and i'm thinking to myself
well lanier's got a lot of choices he
can go rook b8 he can go rook e8 he
could play h6
yeah h6 is useful you could even play
bishop
g6 you can play queen e7 so really i can
understand that you have a larger and
the most critical d5
and then i must say you play you played
the one move
which was number ten
he takes c5 and you help your opponent
bring his piece into play how did you
finally say to yourself hard to explain
and somehow when you have
such a big choice
sometimes strange things happen
i
as i said i was
going to play something like h6 i liked
the move i felt that it's always useful
and it's i didn't want to play queenie
sound just allowing cd6 with this little
tempo right and then i went and then i
saw that maybe he wants to take on d6
and play bishop a6 when he will take on
c6 and
probably give the ball on e4 and reach
some kind of end game i wasn't sure i
didn't want to allow this
i thought maybe this is his preparation
but maybe not and finally i decided to
to keep the queens that's why i took on
c5 but uh yeah that's
hard to say so eventually the 10 minutes
go by you come closer closer to making
this decision to take on the c5 and only
after 30 minutes
finally unleash
because it really was one of the last
moves on my radar i just was curious how
you came finally to making this awkward
move i put it like that no i mean as i
said the main intention was just to
avoid some kind of
end game and just to keep the queen side
i felt that this position with uh with
the knight even with the knight on c5 my
pawns are weak but his pawns are also
very weak and i felt that black has
enough play there to to keep the balance
last question from my side sam
shanklin came on considered yourself
uh to be a favorite in the match how do
you
see the match between yourself as you go
into this playoffs who's the favorite in
your mind i mean it's hard to say i feel
that everything can happen
obviously um
i
honestly i don't find useful i mean
to think if i'm the favorite or not i
know that i have
good chances and that's that's quite
enough for me so exactly i'll go with
that fair enough now linear one of the
most difficult things in chess at least
uh for me is when my opponent plays
quickly and he builds up his time
advantage and i start doubting myself
how do you deal with that how did you
deal with that in this game
yeah it's uh
of course always a little bit unpleasant
when your opponent is playing super fast
and you know that
is well prepared and
but of course the main thing i mean
first of all i'm quite used to this
situation already so it's not like new
for me so in that sense i'm not that
much concerned
and also i mean
first and foremost it's about the
position right so if you have a position
that you feel that uh that it's good
then
uh then you're you're okay i'm not
really too much worried but uh of course
i would prefer when
when my opponent is out of book and uh
it's also taking uh time
linear thank you for joining us and
we'll see you in a few uh linear sorry
uh that uh
you you're getting ready to go and
but i just want to turn your attention
to the game between ray robson
if you don't mind for just a moment
because
obviously you're super experienced
grandmaster
you've sacrificed pieces for pawns in
your life
did you ever get six
bonds
[Laughter]
what's the most you ever gotten maybe
four yeah maybe four
it's quite a lot yeah the four feels
like like like too much already
just wanted to know just yeah i guess
it's hard to to to survive here for vlog
exactly i would assume
yeah all right thank you good luck
thank you for joining us very nice and
of course he will be